he was a force of nature the
quintessential Aussie outdoorsman with
his wicked sense of humor and his
insatiable passion for wildlife Steve
Irwin the Crocodile Hunter became a
worldwide celebrity he shone a spotlight
on man's mismanagement of our natural
resources and champions the plight of
the planet's most vulnerable inhabitants
the animals but Steve was also a
daredevil constantly pushing the limits
in his interactions with the wild then
in a tragic moment he was gone taken
from us far too soon
in today's by graphics we get to grips
with the Crocodile Hunter from Down
Under
[Music]
Stephen Robert Irwin was born on
February the 22nd 1962 in Melbourne
Australia both of his parents were
passionate about wildlife his father Bob
was a plumber but he was also a keen
hepatologist who studied amphibians
while his mother Lynn was a wildlife
rehabilitator when Steve was just a few
years old the family moved to Queensland
where Bob and Lynn opens the Queensland
reptile and fauna park Steve
therefore grew up around reptiles and
was soon put to work at the park he
would clean out the cages and feed the
crocodiles and the lizards by the age of
6 he was accustomed to being around
creatures that most children would be
terrified of his whole existence was
surrounded by wildlife from crocodiles
to kangaroos - koalas the Irwin's
developed their reptile park from
nothing they spent the first couple of
years living in a caravan while they
slowly added to their animal inventory
the first snakes they put on display
were ones that Bob and Steve captured
while out fishing meanwhile Lynn was
busy rehabilitating orphaned Joey's
kangaroos koalas wombats snakes and
crazed at the same time she was raising
three children of her own
Steve proved to be a mischievous child
who was always testing the patience of
his father
he would constantly go missing only to
be discovered down at the local Creek
chasing lizards yet he wasn't being
rebellious he wanted to find venomous
snakes and lizards so that he could show
them to his dad and win his approval but
rather than making him proud
Steve's constant wanderings left Bob
frustrated their boy was hyperactive he
never sat still from the age of two he
developed a skill and love for climbing
trees so the first thing that his family
members would do when he went missing
was look up on the way to school if he
saw a dead reptile lying on the road
Steve would make his mother stop so that
he could get out and investigate when he
was six years old he got the best
present he could have wished for a
12-foot long Python Steve absolutely
adored his new best friend at school
Steve was considered a bit of an oddity
by his peers he wasn't into the normal
boy things like bicycle sports and
skateboards he spends his lunch times
wandering around the schoolyard looking
for birds lizards and any other
creatures that he could find after a
while other kids got involved looking to
Steve as the local expert on all things
related to wildlife Bob Irwin was a hero
and mentor to his son he was a wildlife
innovator who was at the cutting edge of
animal husbandry with the Wildlife Park
established
and a good supply of smaller reptiles
and animals but I decided it was time to
add a couple of crocodiles
he took nine-year-old Steve with him on
his first crocodile hunt as expected the
boy was extremely active and it was all
his dad could do to keep him in the boat
when a croc was sighted Steve would want
to be the first one to grab it he was
positioned at the front of the boat with
the spotlight while his father was
operating the outboard motor as they got
close
Steve fixed his eyes and what he thought
was a small croc then he pounced out of
the boat and got into the water grabbing
his by the neck but the boy he didn't
realize how launched this crocodile was
it was in fact about the same size as
him and quite a bit stronger when it
became clear to Bob that his son was
getting the worst of the encounter he
reached his arm into the water and
scooped up both of them scooping the boy
and the croc into the boat and pinning
the animal down with his body recovering
quickly
Steve took over the job of holding down
the croc with a huge smile on his face
it was one of the proudest moments of
his life so far
[Music]
in the early 70s reports of crocodiles
attacking people were becoming more and
more frequent around Australia as the
stock of crocodiles of the reptile park
grew Bob decided to involve himself in
attempts to resolve the conflicts
between crocodiles and humans he joins
the East Coast crocodile management
program and he and Steve threw
themselves into the task of capturing
and relocating Crocs from areas where
there was potential for a nasty
encounter with humans it was extremely
dangerous work but it was exciting and
young Steve excels yes he had a natural
gift for not only locating the Crocs but
also for capturing them he would get
absolutely focused on catching a
crocodile as if he were entering into
one-on-one combat with it once the croc
was secured and subdued in his net he
would get a huge adrenaline rush which
would make him keen for the next
encounter by the time he was in his late
teens Steve was living in the bush for
extended periods of time camping out
under the stars and spending days at a
time in pursuit of a single croc he had
to live off the land and the water
honing his Bush skills while developing
the mystique of the crocodile hunter it
was grueling work and most of the time
Steve was on his own he was young he was
fit he was keen and he was innovative
Steve became the most successful
Crocodile Hunter in the land with his
growing reputation came a degree of
complacency though he began to feel that
he could do anything on one occasion he
got a croc back to his camp ready to put
it in a crate but he neglected to secure
the animals mouth not realizing this
Steve let the croc out of its nets as he
prepared the crate then with his back
turned the croc attacked snapping its
huge jaws around his neck fortunately
Steve got out of this situation with
nothing but a few holes in his boot on
another occasion Bob went up into
northern Queensland in search of an
infamous croc known as a gray this
creature would pop its head out of the
water right next to the boats horrifying
the locals bob's goal was to locate the
Beast and set up a marker so that his
son could follow up and execute the
capture Bob located the croc easily and
made a mark in an overhanging tree so
that Steve would know where to set the
trap yes from the moments that he went
in Steve could feel that aggro was
stalking him as he was setting the trap
something bumped into his boat and his
dog began barking Steve quickly set the
trap and then left now it was simply a
matter of
watching and waiting on the third day
Steve headed for the site only to
discover that the trap was completely
submerged underwater the bait had been
taken and the trap had gone off Steve
brought his boat close and grabbed a
hold of the nets ready to drag the
captured croc on deck
suddenly there was a massive upheaval as
the croc smashed into the boat from
under the water a stunned Steve managed
to maintain his grip on the net but then
another blow rocks the boat and then
another but Steve he held on and he
began dragging the net in finally he
managed to get the tail on board but
then the entire body of the croc
catapulted out of the water and into the
air coming down beside Steve in the boat
the man and his doc immediately jumped
into the water Steve now grabbed
whatever he could
branches ropes mud and threw it on top
of the violently flashing crocodile the
ideal thing here would have been to
blindfold the animal but that was out of
the question
Steve then jumped into the boat and onto
the back of the crocodile
he threw more Nessun over the beast
trying to cover its eyes and then he
fired up the outboard motor and started
for sure all the way back the crocodile
fought so violently that Steve was
convinced the boat was going to split
apart Steve finally got the one-ton
crocodile secured and restrained back at
his camp his next problem was how to
move it he decided to go back to a local
farm and recruit some helpers but when
the cane farmers saw the size of a grow
they refused to get out of their boat
Steve had to resort to getting a
front-end loader to shift the croc it
was experiences like this that turned
Steve into a local legend but Steve had
mixed feelings he felt bad that he had
to remove aggro from his natural
environment
[Music]
by 1990 Steve had recaptured more than a
hundred Crocs some of them were kept at
the reptile park while the majority were
released into the wild
in 1991 Bob and Linda sided that Steve
had come of age and was ready to take
control of the park
Steve's goal was to make his parents
proud and he knew he would do this by
turning the park into one of the
greatest wildlife facilities on the face
of the earth his first step was to
rename the park Australia Zoo he then
threw himself into creating the most
exciting educational and entertaining
wildlife experience that zoo visitors
would ever experience the highlights
would be the crocodile show where Steve
would be right up close and personal
with Crocs totally in control and
showing no fear he would tell the crowds
what passionate and loving animals they
were with his huge personality and
boundless energy
he quickly won over the public and
tendance figures went through the roof
[Music]
in 1991 among the tens of thousands of
visitors to Australia Zoo was Terry
Raines a veterinarian and animal lover
from the United States she was looking
for a place to relocate Cougars that had
been used in the entertainment industry
she was drawn to their crocodile
demonstration and the fast-talking
Ozzy who was in there with the deadly
creatures Terry she wrote down her
immediate impressions of Steve I thought
there was no one like this anywhere in
the world he sounded like an
environmental Tarzan a larger-than-life
superhero guy Steve managed to catch
sight of Terry in the crowd and
according to him it was love at first
sight the two kindred spirits were
engaged for months after their first
encounter they married in Eugene Oregon
Terry's hometown on June the 4th 1992
Donny moon was spent hunting crocodiles
in northern Queensland to say that Terry
was out of her elements on this trip
would be an understatement she had never
been into the harsh Australian outback
and she definitely hadn't been on a
crocodile hunt before but trusting
implicitly in the man that she referred
to as her prince she threw herself into
the experience accompanying the Irwin's
on their honeymoon adventure with
Steve's friends John Stainton stains in
films the action of the croc hunts and
other adventures including Terry's first
encounter with a six-foot long black
snake this footage became the first
episode of a new Animal Planet TV show
called the Crocodile Hunter the series
which featured both Steve and Terry was
so successful that a second and then a
third series were ordered it was a hit
in over 130 countries with hundreds of
millions of people embracing Steve's
lovable and over-the-top Aussie
personality his trademark catchphrase
crikey became known the world over
crikey crikey the final episodes of
series three were entitled Steve's last
adventure it followed him across the
world is he embarked upon adventures
everywhere from the Himalayas to South
Africa and China the Crocodile Hunter
series allowed Steve to take his
conservation message to the world he
viewed it as his life's mission to work
tirelessly to save the world's
endangered species as a result of his
name recognition
he became the frontman for a number of
media campaigns and became
at ambassador for Australian tourism
Steve crusaded for wildlife preservation
using his fame to bring the issue to the
public consciousness in the late 1990s
he also discovered a new species of sea
turtle and was at the forefront of a
campaign against animal poaching he also
funded large nature reserves not just in
Australia but also in Fiji Vanuatu and
the United States
Irwin's TV series Fame led to more
television and even some movie work he
appears in 2001 dr. Dolittle 2 as
himself and then starred in the
Crocodile Hunter collision course the
following year in 2006 he provided the
voice for an elephant seal named Trev in
the movie happy feet the money that
Steve made from his TV and movie
appearances was poured into building new
exhibits for Australia Zoo and for
funding conservation projects the zoo
was designed as an animal park with the
comfort of the animals being the
foremost concern fences and cages would
only be used when absolutely necessary
the staff at the zoo grew to about 50
and the area grew to take up about 100
acres the zoo won the award for best
Australian tourist attraction in 2003 to
2004 in 2004 the Australian Animal
Hospital was opened right next to the
zoo Hospital cares for around 6000
animals each year in 2006 australia zoo
retail won the Australian tourism
retailing award
[Music]
Stephen Terry had two children together
bhindi born in 1998 and robert in 2003
bindis birth was filmed and shown on TV
for the Crocodile Hunter series Steve
had been filming for the show when he
got the call that Terry's waters have
broken he turns up at the hospital two
hours later with a complete film crew in
tow
Terry was surprised but as was their
nature she took it all in her stride
they were both delighted when they found
out they had a baby girl Stephen knew
instantly what the name was going to be
bindi su after his favorite croc and his
favorite dog Steve was the
self-proclaimed proudest father on the
face of the earth he and bindi bonded
instantly becoming virtually inseparable
she went on to her first wildlife
documentary shoot at just six days old
bindi would grow up in the international
spotlight starring in her own show
bindi jungle girl when she was 8 years
old although the series aired the year
after Steve's passing it was shot before
he died and so he featured in several
episodes
[Music]
November of 2003 found Steve filming a
documentary off the coast of Baja
California peninsula in Mexico about sea
lions a report came through the boats
radio that a pair of scuba divers were
missing in the area
Steve immediately shut down filming and
joined the search the next day members
of his crew found one of the divers
clinging to a rocky cliff edge Stevens
another rescuer brought the man back to
their boat the other man's body was
located a short time after in early 2004
Steve made the news for the wrong
reasons when video was shown of him
feeding a chicken carcass to a 12 and a
half foot saltwater crocodile while
holding his 1 month old infant son child
welfare and animal rights groups alike
condemned the action with some referring
to it as child abuse both Steve and
Terry contended that he had full control
over the situation nevertheless Steve
did apologize doing so on the American
Channel and BC the incidents prompted
the queensland government to enact a law
stating that no untrained persons or
children were allowed inside a crocodile
enclosure steve was also criticized for
his conservation views which some viewed
as overly simplistic and weighted
towards tourism the Sydney Morning
Herald wrote that his message boiled
down to eating Roos and Crocs is bad for
tourism and therefore more cruel than
eating other animals there were however
other industry experts who poured preys
upon Owen and the work that he had done
to raise the public's awareness of
conservation issues mark Townsend the
CEO of Queensland's RSPCA called him a
modern-day Noah while a Canadian
environmentalist remarked after Steve's
passing that humanity will not protect
that which we fear or do not understand
Steve Irwin helps us understand those
things that many people thought were a
nuisance at best horror at worst that
made him a great educator and
conservationist
Steve's own conservation mentor was
British conservationist and filmmaker
Sir David Attenborough a month after
Steve's death tario and presented
Attenborough with a Lifetime Achievement
Award in his acceptance speech
Sir David praised Steve saying that he
taught people how wonderful and exciting
nature was and he was a born
communicator
[Music]
throughout his 44 years
Steve had taken on and defeated many of
the most dangerous creatures on the
planet
it was ironic then that the animal that
would get the better of him was a
normally tranquil fish on September the
4th 2006 he was filming off Australia's
Great Barrier Reef for a documentary to
be called ocean's deadliest the weather
had been bad for several days so Steve
had been sitting around with little to
do but wait for the weather to improve
that day he decided to do some
snorkeling in the shallow waters which
could be filmed for his daughter bindis
new TV show he got down into the water
which was only at chest height seeing a
large blue bull stingray he came over
the top of it in order to film it as it
swam away however just as he hovered
above it the stingray thrust up its tail
and began stabbing upward a bob was shot
directly into Steve's chest he
immediately pulled it out and rose to
the top and struggled to get back into
the boat the crew administered CPR and
then rushed him to the nearest hospital
but he was announced dead on arrival
Steve's legacy lives on through his wife
Terry and his children bindi and Robert
these three wildlife warriors continue
to run Australia Zoo and to honor the
memory of this truly amazing man so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic if you did there's a couple
of things you could do right now one is
hit that like button below also if you
want more stuff like this we put out
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right
thank you for watching
[Music]
you